[Music]
foreign
welcome to 20 minute leaders thank you
michael
how's it going it's going fantastic you
know i did i did quite a few
shows so far and this is the one the
first one that i'm doing twice
and i'm especially excited for the
second one rather than the first one
i'm really happy for our second one it's
gonna be great
it's getting the first one it's gonna be
fantastic okay sorry
uh made in jerusalem a an incredible
community
uh tell me a little bit about what
you're doing in you're calling from
jerusalem
you love jerusalem and what is made in
so made in jerusalem is a community
organization where a nonprofit we helped
develop the jerusalem startup and tech
scene
and our job here is just to make sure
that the city
grows and companies can come here and
stay
here and grow and yeah we do that
through all kinds of initiatives
helping supporting community leaders and
doing things like
courses and working with companies to
promote their jobs
and helping the city solve issues like
office space and all kinds of
city related challenges so you know
jerusalem and i mentioned this last time
as well when i think of jerusalem i
don't think you know
necessarily startups and and high-tech
and start-up nation i think of
religion i think of conflict they think
of history
yet you're coming in and saying no we we
need to develop the high-tech
infrastructure in the community within
the city so where does that come from
yeah so i i think first of all when you
when you think of jerusalem
um i think it doesn't get enough credit
for
being um first of all the largest city
here in israel and israel itself is kind
of a powerhouse
and and i think the fact that it's the
largest city effect
it's a capital city it's a very global
city with the largest tourism in israel
people coming every every person who
comes to israel
almost has to come through jerusalem at
some point so
um it has a lot of unique advantages as
a city
economically right uh that are very
interesting and i think that
today jerusalem is one of the biggest
kind of cities and brands
in the world that if you look at the
potential
of what the city could be and if you
look at what it is today
there's a lot to improve here and i
think that from an entrepreneurial
perspective
is interesting and if you're kind of
investing your
time and efforts in the city i think
jerusalem is one of the most interesting
places to do that because it could go
so much further and we talked about it a
bit last time or maybe come to it again
but i think it has
a lot of significance here not only in
the context of israel but
in the whole kind of context of the
middle east and the special place that
it has
between kind of the
[Music]
israeli community and the arab
communities in the region so
totally totally sorry give me give me
some numbers to shed some light on
what is the gap that we're seeing what
is happening today versus what do you
think
could happen if we worked a little bit
harder on developing this community over
there yeah so so i think that the big
challenge
of jerusalem is that we have
around 40 percent of the city our era
and it's one community that has a very
low participation
in the workforce uh here in josiah and
almost i think i don't want to get any
specific numbers because
i don't understand but it's a big
percent of unemployment
especially in the arab sector
the women stay at home and and the men
usually go to work for
in low weight jobs then we have 25
percent of the city
that is ultra-orthodox a jewish and it's
a special
type of judaism that only exists
basically here
it's a population that kind of some of
them
it's a very diverse population and
there's many opinions but
the general kind of approach is the
community
is afraid of the internet doesn't it is
not sending people to go to
study studying there is a big kind of
you're a rebel if you go to university
and going to work is something very
special and over there it's the women
who usually go to work
and are the first who go to study and
become developers and companies and then
the men
study at yeshiva and they study the
bible and
i mean that's changing now those two
populations are in a big period of
change
um but it means that more than
two-thirds of the city
are some of the lowest participating um
kind of people in the workforce not only
in jerusalem but in
any modern city so
for a city if you think of it kind of
how how a city is it
able to survive and make money you have
to
um have some percent of your population
bringing money from the outside doing
export basically
sure and then from that money they can
rent office space they can pay
um food services they can pay for taxis
they can pay for
any service city provides and that first
of all provides employment for other
people but it also
provides tax to the city for every one
of those actions that you do every
interaction every
area house that you rent or office
office space is some of the best kind of
money maker for cities
and so if you're in a city that has less
office spaces or less large corporate
brands
um that are able to to not only
rent the spaces that exist but also
develop new uh buildings
and if there's no that kind of money if
that kind of money only exists kind of
in private housing
offenses and the city is losing so i
think what we need to do here
in jerusalem today jerusalem is losing
money all the time
it gets a grant from the government
because
obviously a majority of its population
is basically not working right
so it has all these people it has to
give services for
but they're not making enough money to
pay back in taxes so
you have a situation today where most of
the people if you look
above average salary wage in jerusalem
which is about
2 000 something dollars
and if you look above that most of the
people
90 something percent of the people in
jerusalem who have that wage
are either working for the government or
working in a government subsidized area
like hospitals or education
right or any other one of these other
things welfare
and so you're always like even the
people who are making money they're not
making
money from the outside they're not
bringing in the money they're using
taxpayer dollars for their own salaries
so i think that's the big challenge of
jerusalem and to be a city
that is leading globally we have to kind
of balance that out and find
ways to to make money and yeah our kind
of
vision for that is that we think that if
we can do things
um if we can bring industries like
high-tech into jerusalem
and there's been a huge growth in
high-tech and jerusalem in the past few
years
the coming from the community i'll maybe
get back to that later
but if we can do that in more areas like
media or
i don't know gaming anything that we see
from the ground up that people are
already doing in jerusalem but just
help them do more of it and help
investors come and help them do it on a
global scale
right that's something that i think is
going to help the city
go to a next level and what i think is
really going to make it go to the next
level is if we can make those places
accessible
to those populations that are right in
the workforce so right
i mean like yours yeah so i mean you're
you're an entrepreneur
right like all of us and yet you're not
you're not saying yeah i'm gonna go to
this crazy startup and i'm gonna raise
millions of dollars and i'm gonna go
try and think for the exit strategy
you're saying there's a city that i
really truly love
that i think i as an entrepreneur have
the potential to change and transform
and you're really sort of taking things
that you know
a mayor would do or prime minister would
i mean it's really it's it's really odd
for an entrepreneur
to do something like this isn't it yeah
yeah sort of it's something that i
kind of had to accept so so my
history before that i did have a small
startup and i did go to work for a
company in the city called orcam which
is uh unicorn and
from the founders of mobilei yes and
and at some point i had to accept that
what i'm doing here for the city and
with the city
is much more interesting it's much more
interesting i think also
in the entrepreneurial perspective it's
more interesting in the sense that it
takes more of my time
and and i don't feel like i'm working
what i'm doing it's just fun
but also i think we're we're good at it
i think the results are
things are happening and we it's really
rewarding
to see those things that you do actually
make an impact on this huge and historic
city
like jerusalem there's there's no more
historic city
than jerusalem with like thousands of
years of kind of fighting over
and i think to be kind of in your 20s
and be able to have an impact on places
like that when people
come to jerusalem and they want to meet
the high-tech industry that they send
them to you and you're like a kid
and it's i think that's something that's
very interesting um
and that can be built upon and it's kind
of i don't know
i think we have much uh more interesting
things to do in the future
once we solve the challenges that are
here today there's much more going ahead
and
also i think it's a challenge for me to
think
of the kind of the business models in
that space because
if being an entrepreneur's heart being a
non-profit entrepreneur
is kind of all the rules that
are just exist to make life easier for
you as an entrepreneur
are there to make life harder for you as
a non-profit because you're kind of
getting all these tax benefits and then
the government kind of sees you
as sort of a criminal in a way it's like
no you can't use a credit card because
if you use a credit card you'll embezzle
us it's like
what are you talking about it's a credit
card it's like everybody should be using
your credit card
there's all these kinds of things that
should there are hard that shouldn't be
hard
as a non-profit entrepreneur so i think
that's a challenge too and
i'm getting used to the to it that kind
of that is what we are in a way
so what right what what is happening
within made in jerusalem made in jlm
tangibly i mean where how do you
interact with the people how do you get
them to become a part of the community
and talk to me a bit about the whole
process that you're doing there
yeah so i think at the beginning we were
walking around
the studio and we just talked to people
who worked in tech or were studying tech
or
i don't know investors and and the same
thing we heard from everyone
is that kind of they think they're the
only one in tech in the city
everybody left and if you talk to
entrepreneurs they would say that
like i have this cool idea and i'm here
for like another
few weeks but i'm probably not going to
stay here and i have all my startup
events are somewhere else or just or the
investors or someone
and what we did in the beginning was
just to start bringing
those people together and showing them
that hey do you know this person it was
small introductions one by one and then
gradually
events and facebook groups and sharing
kind of news if you heard that the
company was raising funding because you
were just
at their offices and they told you and
then you would look for
the article or something and share it so
more people would know
and gradually started building and
just that by itself just connecting kind
of people around those
events and then between events online on
facebook
and we we saw that the numbers between
when we started doing that which is like
2012 and
three years later even 2014-15
so you had like this growth where
there used to be 20 new startups listed
on the israeli company registrar every
year in jerusalem
and then by 2015 it's 100 companies
every year
and then you had that same growth with
investors it was 50 million dollars
a per year in 2012 and then and that was
flat for a long time and then it
suddenly grew
each year until 250 in 2015 and so
until then in 2015 we were listed
in jerusalem in time magazine it's one
of the top five emerging tech hubs
in startup campus is one of the top 30
uh
tech cities it was a list of eight round
rocks to the top 20 tech cities
and then later on i think today where
there's also lists for
ai cities and biotech cities and we're
always in the top 10
wow for those because jerusalem has kind
of a mobile eye and the hebrew that's
doing amazing
things with ai and most of the top
companies here are ai related
so it's a lot of science coming from
university in the labs
and then leaking out and then you have
the hospitals here you have
that's the hospital intelligence
so there's other innovation around that
um
yeah so that was kind of 2012 to 2015
but now there are other challenges so i
think
what the community did just this aspect
of bringing people together
was a great retention so it helped keep
people in here for for a while because
you're starting your startup so the
beginning you don't need
much you need somebody to show you the
ropes like an accelerator
or meetups and things like that like how
to start a startup and
all these kind of big things you need a
place to work so you need like a cool
co-working space where other people
are doing things and we we had a few of
the first
ones starting up in only 2012 and
and so you start taking care of those
basic needs and you have companies
staying instead of one month they stay
the first year they stay the first two
years and then they find an investor
within those two years because you have
investors who are only
uh looking at companies in jerusalem
ventures and yeah i don't know
definitely also really
with some of their funds so
i think that was a big first
step that was the the thing that kind of
made the jump
and then the next thing that i think
we're focused on now as a community
is um now that you have all these people
working together and you have the
leaders of these communities working
together
first of all we're kind of developing
the next generation of leaders now so
you have
the general tech community but you also
have the ai community and the
developer the front-end developer
community and
designers and designers who are also
ultra also
ready women so and kids and so you have
all these kinds of different populations
and industries and professions that all
need
somebody to connect them and to solve
the problems that are unique to them
so i'm very curious what do you see
i want to hear about your fee about your
experience
how do you take a population that is you
know not as
and it's not as in the in their mindset
in the forefront of
of going to work and high tech and
technology sometimes it it
almost seems contradictory to the way
that they live their life
and you come and say hey listen there's
this new thing this cool thing that we
can all
work together to to improve on is it do
you how far do you have to go to
convince them
or sort of how much resistance do you
see when you just start out planting the
seeds
for that growth yeah so
i think it always has to start bottom up
you can't
come and kind of impose yourself right
on people who want
it to join it it always has to be
someone from that community
who says like i want to be
um leading that growth and
bringing more people into that space in
my community
right and and then you kind of help them
do that little by little
it could be like we we really love
starting small like if you sometimes do
an event with
i know a thousand people in the end
you would still have like maybe five
people who
stay connected right after that who made
it something and
it's sometimes much easier to bring
out five people to coffee to begin with
and then all those
100 of those five people will stay
connected so so starting small
and doing things that um
gradually just like starting to to
collect the the leaders
of like the people in that community who
are influential and maybe have a
position
in tech invested before work for a tech
company or whatever and just finding
those
people who are also first of all they're
the connectors and the hub
so they can help the other population
and then
um they also are kind of role models and
there are people who have achieved
something that maybe other people in the
community want
to achieve for themselves and so i think
that's the beginning
we see something that's a bit
controversial and we we
having talked to a lot of communities i
see that a lot of people have the same
reactions when people
will do it is um sometimes to
kind of bring people uh together to a
new
thing like bring i don't know students
to the tech community and connect them
to the outside tech world
and sometimes to do that you have to do
something very counterintuitive
which is to start a tech community
that's only for students
so the first reaction people have is to
like say wait but if
we keep them in a bubble and they're
already only talking to themselves
and how would they get connected to the
large tech community
but we see that if you try to bring them
out to the community you get like
you market 200 students you get two
students coming out to those big deck
events
but when you do an event on campus you
get 100 students
and and you bring someone to them but
then the next time you do an event
outside
you won't get two students you'll get 10
students and then if you keep going
you'll get 20 students and 50 students
to come out
so we call that transition communities
this this kind of middle stage where you
do need to stay in your bubble but you
bring the content to them it's something
that's very
important i think in a community that
isn't involved and it's something that
always creates
um kind of even outrage you know like
when you have
sure it's a women in tech community and
we're gonna do events only for women
yeah and like some people go mad it's
like what are you doing it's the
complete opposite of what you should be
doing you should be
mixing everyone together but sometimes
before you mix everyone together
you first need to create that kind of
identity and self-assurance
in that small group first ray what is
one thing that you would give
as an advice to any you know upcoming
social entrepreneur that wants to make
some positive change in their community
maybe looking back over the last uh the
the last
decade what would you do uh what would
not what would you differently but
what insight would you that now bring on
to others
that you wish you had before
yeah so it's really hard i think
everything is possible like every
problem that you
think is like oh this hasn't been solved
for 100 years it's probably solvable
it's just i think first of all you have
to understand
the system and and you have to really go
and ask all the questions and ask
everybody everything like why is this
done this way and why
and who is in charge of that and who are
the players
and i think that once you have that map
in your head you can do things that are
much more
effective the the other thing is is
i mentioned to start small i think that
by bringing one person
and two people and 10 people onto this
mission
you'll create this rolling ball of
something crazy that happens without you
even noticing it and there's a network
effect to like more people who are
working on this problem
the faster things happen and um
yeah just i think there's two
to come with a smile and said that um
if something's impossible it's just like
maybe we're trying to early do a few
things before and
and then build up to it gradually i
think you can always build
if something it's possible that
something is too hard but with anything
like with anything else it's a skill you
just need to build to the point where
you're a bit stronger and then you can
solve it
100 ray right before we go i need
three words that describe you best
yeah yeah so we did it last time and i
don't remember what it is
i'm gonna fact-check you on this
hopelessly
optimistic i'm optimistic i think that
we're getting things are getting better
all the time um
i really don't remember what else i
think i'm passionate about what
yeah you do and i think that this
passion is really important
because otherwise you wouldn't invest
all that time doing those crazy things
um and yeah what hopeful i think was the
the last one or was that the first one
i think that was the first one yeah the
positive hopeful
uh i don't know um
i'm i have no idea any other
good things that other people said that
i can copy
um well you know i think i think what i
i mean i think it's just it was so
interesting to to meet people that
go from this tech world and then they
embark on this
personal uh intimate journey
where they think they can empower other
people and they can empower different
communities to bring social change
and you're working with the top leaders
in israel in the tech community to shed
light
on jerusalem and i think that's just
remarkable by itself
and uh and optimistic and hopeful i
think that's
exactly what every social entrepreneur
and needs to needs to consider
themselves sorry
thank you very very much for the time uh
really really great stuff and
and continue doing amazing things thanks
perfect all right take care bye bye
bye
hey